BACK TO YOU.
>> Sandra: MIKE TOBIN,
THANK YOU.
>> Ed: FOR MORE ON THIS, LET’S
BRING IN SHERIFF OF BERRY COUNTY
MICHIGAN.
THANKS FOR COMING IN.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE SHERIFFS WHO
IS SAYING I’M NOT GOING TO
LISTEN TO GOVERNOR WHITMER.
I’M GOING TO DEFY THE ORDER.
WHY?
>> WE ARE NOT SAYING WE ARE NOT
GOING TO LISTEN TO
GOVERNOR WHITMER.
WE ARE GOING TO USE COMMON SENSE
WHEN IT COMES TO ENFORCING IT.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE BEING RESPECTFUL
AND USING THAT 6-FOOT RANGE AND,
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GO ABOUT AND
START TELLING PEOPLE TO GO HOME.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WHEN HASTINGS HERE, WE HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO OUT
AND DO SOME FISHING.
THEY ARE AT HOME AND WE HAVE AN
ORDER RIGHT NOW THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A KAYAK IN A CANOE BUT YOU
CAN’T HAVE A MOTORBOAT.
I WANT PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
HOUSE, WE HAVE AN UPTICK OF
DOMESTICS FROM OUR 911 CENTER
AND I WANT PEOPLE TO GET AWAY
FROM THE HOUSE, WHAT BETTER
PLACE THAN OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
A LAKE WHEN NOBODY’S AROUND YOU?
>> Ed: I UNDERSTAND.
GOVERNOR WHITMER WAS ON ABC THIS
MORNING AND SEEMED TO DISMISS
SOME OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID AND
SAID THIS IS ALL ABOUT SAVING
LIVES.
WATCH.
>> SHARES MAKING A POINT, THAT’S
FINE.
I CAN TAKE IT.
IT MAKES PEOPLE FEEL BETTER TO
TAKE THEIR FRUSTRATIONS OUT ON
ME, THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
BETTER TO BE 6 FEET APART RIGHT
NOW THAN 6 FEET UNDER AND THAT
IS THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS.
WE FOUGHT TO SAVE LIVES.
EVERYONE MATTERS.
>> Ed: THIS IS ABOUT SAVING
LIVES, WHICH I’M ASSUMING YOU
CLEARLY WANT TO DO WHEN YOU MADE
THAT CLEAR IN YOUR FIRST ANSWER
AS WELL, BUT SHE WAS DISMISSIVE.
SHE SAID THIS IS 4 OUT OF 83
SHERIFFS AND THEY’RE MAKING A
POLITICAL POINT.
>> IS NOT POLITICAL, IT’S MORE
COMMON SENSE.
SOMEBODY’S OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
A LAKE AND AWAY FROM EVERYBODY
AROUND THEIR LAWN MOWER IN THEIR
100 YARDS AWAY FROM PEOPLE,
THAT’S WHERE WE WANT THEM.
WE DON’T WANT THEM BOTTLED UP
INSIDE THE HOUSE WHEN THEY START
ARGUING AND START DRINKING
ALCOHOL AND I THINK THAT’S
REASONABLE.
>> Ed: YOU ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE PENDULUM IS
SWINGING A BIT AND THAT THERE
WERE SOME JUSTIFIABLE REASONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY
CAME FIRST, BUT THAT NOW MAY BE
SOME THINGS HAVE GONE TOO FAR
AND PEOPLE ARE STANDING UP FOR
THEIR RIGHTS?
>> YES, I AGREE WITH SOME OF
THAT.
THAT CURVE THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT IS FLATTENING AND RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE IN KIND OF THE PEAK
OF WHAT THEY SAID WAS GOING TO
HIT.
A WEEK AGO, WE HAD SEVEN THAT
WERE POSITIVE, ONE THAT WAS
RECOVERED, AND WE HAD ONE DEATH.
NOW WE ARE UP TO 16 AND THIS WAS
YESTERDAY.
I HAVEN’T CHECKED TODAY’S
NUMBERS YET.
WE STILL HAVE THE ONE DEATH BUT
WE HAVE TWO OR THREE.
>> Ed: WE CERTAINLY HOPE THAT
CONTINUES TO FLATTEN NOT JUST IN
MICHIGAN BUT ALL ACROSS THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
WE’VE BEEN THINKING HEALTH CARE
WORKERS WORKING ON THE FRONT
LINES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE FRONT
LINES AS WELL, WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR VIEWS.
>> THANK YOU.
I WANT EVERYONE TO RESPECT THE
HEALTH WORKERS.
YOU CAN STAY AT HOME, STAY AT
HOME BUT IF YOU NEED TO GET OUT
AND WALK OUT, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BOTHER YOU ON THAT.
YOU NEED TO WALK OR GET ON THE
BOAT, SOME PEOPLE ARE GETTING ON
THE BACK ROADS.